THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
ANGLE.
>> WE’VE ENTERED THE SPRINT TO
NOVEMBER AND THE ANGLE IS BACK
TO TRANSLATE JOE BIDEN’S WORD
FOR YOU.
HE HAS TRIED MIGHTILY TO MUDDY
THE WATERS ON HIS REAL VIEWS AND
ACTUAL RECORD OF SUPPORTING WARS
.
>> DO YOU SAY YOUR VOTE ON THE
IRAQ WAR WAS BASED ON THE
PRESIDENTS REPUTATION SAID THIS
WASN’T ABOUT GOING TO WAR, THIS
WAS ABOUT PRESENTING A CLEAR AT
LEAST THREAT TO SADDAM HUSSEIN?
BERNIE SANDERS HAS EYES ALRIGHT
THROUGH THAT.
CAN WE SAY THAT SENATOR SANDERS
JUDGMENT ABOUT THAT WAS BETTER
THAN YOURS?
>> LOOK, THE REASON I VOTED THE
WAY I DID WAS TO TRY TO PREVENT
A WAR FROM HAPPENING.
>> IT IS COMPLETELY FALSE.
AND ANYONE WHO HAS ANY MOMENTARY
MEMORY OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING AT
THE TIME IN 2002 AND 2003 KNOWS
THAT.
THIS IS WHY BIDEN HAS SOUGHT TO
CAPITALIZE ON THE NOW DEBUNKED
ATLANTIC MAGAZINE SMEAR AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE MOST INCENDIARY CLAIMS
IN THAT PIECE HAVE BEEN
DISAVOWED BY AT LEAST 21 CURRENT
OR FORMER ADMINISTRATION SOURCES
ON THE RECORD, BY THE WAY.
TICKET NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER
TALKED ABOUT OUR SERVICEMEN AND
WOMEN IN THAT WAY.
I’M SORRY IF I’M COMING CLOSE TO
LOSING MY TEMPER, BUT THE SIMPLE
TRUTH IS, IF THAT’S HOW YOU TALK
ABOUT OUR VETERANS, YOU HAVE NO
BUSINESS BEING PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
PERIOD.
>> THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN OF COURSE
IS EAGER TO DRIVE A WEDGE
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
MOST LOYAL CONSTITUENCIES AND HE
HAPPILY TOOK THE ASSIST FROM
ATLANTIC WRITER JEFFREY GOLDBERG
WHO USED ANONYMOUS SOURCES TO
CONJURE UP THE BOGUS CLAIM THAT
TRUMP CANCELED HIS VISIT TO AN
AMERICAN MILITARY CEMETERY IN
FRANCE TO YEARS AGO BECAUSE HE
DIDN’T BELIEVE IN HONORING
VIOLENT HEROES.
GOLDBERG WENT ON TO CLAIM IN A
CONVERSATION WITH SENIOR STAFF
MEMBERS ON THE MORNING OF THE
SCHEDULED VISIT TRUMP SAID WHY
SHOULD I GO TO THAT CEMETERY
FILLED WITH LOSERS.
IN A SEPARATE CONVERSATION ON
THE SAME TRIP, HE REFERRED TO
THE MORE THAN 1800 MARINES WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES AS SUCKERS FOR
GETTING KILLED.
THIS ISN’T THE FIRST TIME THAT
GOLDBERG CITED ANONYMOUS SOURCES
TO PROP UP A RIDICULOUS CLAIM.
FOR THE FIRST TIME HIS WRITING
FITS SEAMLESSLY WITH THE PRO-
WAR PARTY AGENDA.
BACK IN FEBRUARY OF 2003, WHILE
WRITING FOR THE NEW YORKER,
GOLDBERG WAS BUSY SELLING THE
DIRECT WMD CLAIM AND THE IDEA
THAT SADDAM HUSSEIN HAD IN SOME
WAY AIDED AND ABETTED AL QAEDA.
HE WAS ONE OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL JOURNALISTS IN THE
UNITED STATES WHOSE REPORTING
LED TO A BROAD PUBLIC ACCEPTANCE
FOR INVADING IRAQ.
HERE IS AN INTERVIEW WITH ROBERT
SIEGEL HE DID OF NPR.
>> AND ALL OF YOUR REPORTING ON
AL QAEDA AND IRAQ, WHAT IS THE
STRONGEST PIECE OF EVIDENCE THAT
WOULD SUGGEST THERE REALLY IS A
LINK BETWEEN THE TWO?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO SAY IT
SOMETHING I LEARNED OF RECENTLY
AND HAVING THIS NEW STORY, WHICH
IS IN THE MID- 90s, SERIES OF
EMISSARIES WENT FROM AFGHANISTAN
EARLIER FROM SUDAN TO BAGHDAD TO
CONVINCE THE IRAQI INTELLIGENCE
SERVICE TO PROVIDE AL QAEDA WITH
CHEMICAL WEAPONS TRAINING IN
AFGHANISTAN.
ACCORDING TO MY SOURCES, THEY
SUCCEEDED AND IRAQIS DID IN FACT
HELP AL QAEDA IN THE TEACHING OF
THE USE OF POISON GAS.
>> WHILE MANY OF US INCLUDING
THIS HOST TOOK THAT REPORTING AS
GOSPEL, BIG MISTAKE.
WELL AT LEAST I DID A REAL MEA
CULPA AND CHANGE MY THINKING
COMPLETELY ABOUT THESE TYPES OF
PREEMPTIVE WARS, SPECIFICALLY
THOSE IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
AND ENDED UP BELIEVING THAT THEY
WOULD MAKE US WEAKER ACROSS THE
BOARD AS THEY DID, BUT MISTER
GOLDBERG DID NOT.
ALTHOUGH YEARS LATER HE
DELIVERED US APOLOGY FOR HIS
ROLE IN PEDDLING THIS PRO-
INVASION NARRATIVE, HE
NEVERTHELESS INSISTED THAT ON
THE DIGNITY OF THE STORY THE
ORIGINAL STORY.
THE DIGNITY OF A STORY THAT
ENDED UP SUPPORTING A WAR THAT
COST TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
LIVES OF OVER 4,400 AMERICANS.
SUCH AS THE HUBRIS OF AN
UNREPENTANT LIBERAL
INTERVENTIONIST.
THIS BRINGS US BACK TO JOE BIDEN
.
WHY DID MISTER GOLDBERG, AFTER
HIS HUGE IRAQI WAR
EMBARRASSMENTS, PULL A STUNT
LIKE THIS IN THE CAMPAIGNS
HOMESTRETCH?
TO PROP UP THE CANDIDACY OF THE
AGING WAR HAWK HIMSELF, JOE
BIDEN.
THAT WHY.
BIDEN LAUGHABLY HAS TRIED TO
CLAIM THAT DESPITE HAVING VOTED
FOR THE WAR, HE WAS AGAINST IT
ALMOST AS SOON AS IT STARTED.
IN REALITY, BIDEN WAS PUSHING
FOR MILITARY INTERVENTION IN
IRAQ FIVE YEARS BEFORE THE
INVASION.
THIS WAS A 1998 FOREIGN FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING.
>> MANY BELIEVE AS LONG AS
SADDAM IS AT THE HOME, THERE IS
NO REASONABLE PROSPECT.
YOU OR ANY OTHER INSPECTOR IS
EVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GUARANTEE THAT WE HAVE ROUTED
OUT ROOT AND BRANCH, THE
ENTIRETY OF SADDAM’S PROGRAM
RELATIVE TO WHAT WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
THE ONLY WAY WE ARE GOING TO GET
RID OF SADDAM HUSSEIN IS WE ARE
GOING TO END UP HAVING TO START
IT ALONE, STARTED ALONE, AND
IT’S GOING TO REQUIRE GUYS LIKE
YOU IN UNIFORM TO BE BACK ON
FOOT, IN THE DESERT TAKING
SADDAM DOWN.
>> FIRST OF ALL, HE’S BEEN IN
POLITICS A LONG TIME, RIGHT?
BUT BEFORE HE WON THE NOMINATION
, HIS RECORD ON WARS
WAS ACTUALLY BEGINNING TO CATCH
UP TO HIM.
THE LEFT-WING ANTI- TRUMP
WEBSITE WAS INCREDULOUS THAT
PARTY MIGHT ACTUALLY NOMINATE A
WAR HAWK LIKE BIDEN TO GO UP
AGAINST TRUMP WHO WON IN PART BY
TAKING ON THE WAR HAWKS IN HIS
OWN PARTY.
IN BIDEN’S EXPLANATIONS WEREN’T
WASHING.
WHAT BIDEN DID IS WAS TO HELP
ENSURE WAR HAPPENED WHILE TRYING
TO WASH HIS HANDS OF
RESPONSIBILITY FOR IT.
HE HELPED BUILD THE CAR FOR BUSH
, FILLED IT UP WITH GAS, SAW
THAT BUSH WAS DRUNK, GAVE HIM
LICENSED TO DO WHAT HE WANTED,
EVENTUALLY, BIDEN PRETENDED HE
WAS SHOCKED AT THAT THE STREAKS
WERE LITTERED WITH MANGLED
BODIES.
THE INTERCEPT WHICH IS ANOTHER
ANTIWAR ANTI- TRUMP SITE HAS
ALSO CALLED OUT BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS IN GENERAL FOR THEIR
OWN LONG HISTORY OF SUPPORTING
WARS OF PREEMPTION.
INTOXICATED BY THE MAELSTROM OF
CRISES BOTH DOMESTIC AND GLOBAL,
THERE’S BEEN LITTLE ACCOUNTING
FOR THESE TRAGEDIES.
THE IMPACT OF THE WARS DID NOT
AIR MENTION AT THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION, BUT IN THE
END, CATASTROPHE OF THIS SCALE
CAN’T JUST BE BRUSHED ASIDE.
AND BIDEN CLAIMS THAT DONALD
TRUMP HAS DISRESPECTED THE
TROOPS?
A PATHETIC DRIVE-BY SMEAR, AND A
DESPERATE ATTEMPT TO COVER UP
HIS OWN LIES ABOUT HIS OWN
HISTORY OF RUBBERSTAMPING
WHATEVER THE PRO-
INTERVENTIONIST TYPES WANTED.
THE MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
WAS NEVER COMFORTABLE WITH TRUMP
DESPITE THE MASSIVE INCREASE IN
SPENDING HE PUSHED BACK IN 2017,
WHILE THE NEOCONS AND THE
FOREIGN POLICY ESTABLISHMENT
SEIZED ON GOLDBERG’S HIT PIECE,
THEY KNEW THAT HE, THE GENERALS
KNEW HE ASKED UNCOMFORTABLE
QUESTIONS LIKE WHY ARE WE STILL
IN GERMANY 75 YEARS AFTER WORLD
WAR II ENDED?
AND WHY ARE PEOPLE MORE WORRIED
ABOUT RUSSIA TODAY THEN CHINA?
AND WHY DOESN’T NATO NATIONS,
WHY DON’T THEY CONTRIBUTE MORE
FOR THEIR OWN MILITARY DEFENSE
AGAIN?
A LOT OF THESE WAR HAWKS DON’T
LIKE ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS
WERE HAVING THEM ASK AT ALL.
AND THEY KNOW THAT BIDEN WILL
NOT ASK THEM.
HE WON’T DEMAND ANSWERS TO ANY
OF THOSE QUESTIONS.
THAT’S WHY THEY LIKE HIM.
SIMPLY STATED, BIDEN IS A
LIFETIME MEMBER OF THE PRO- WAR
PRO- SURVEILLANCE STATE CROWD IN
THE FAR LEFT EPITOMIZED BY THE
SQUAD, THEY DON’T LIKE ANY OF
THIS, THEY DON’T LIKE IT, BUT IT
SEEMS THEY HAVE MADE IN IMPLICIT
DOUBLE BARGAIN THAT THEY WILL
CONTROL SOCIAL POLICY TO PUSH
REPARATIONS AND COURT
APPOINTMENTS AND A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THEN THEY
WILL LOOK THE OTHER WAY, AT
LEAST FOR NOW WHEN IT COMES TWO
FOREIGN POLICY.
THE REST OF US DON’T HAVE TO
MAKE THAT BARGAIN.
DO YOU KNOW WHY?
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A CANDIDATE WHO
FIGHTS WHAT EISENHOWER CALLED
THE MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
MAN WHO SEEKS TO BRING OUR
TROOPS HOME FROM ENDLESS
UNNECESSARY WARS, AND WHO
RECOGNIZES THAT WE CAN’T SOLVE
ALL OF OUR PROBLEMS BY BOMBING
THEM.
IF YOU WANT TO REIN IN THE
PENTAGON, PRESIDENT TRUMP AS THE
ONLY CREDIBLE OPTION.
OF VOTE FOR BIDEN WILL LEAD US
BACK TO THE DISASTROUS POLICIES